hello there welcome to the heavy
spoilers show
i'm your host paul and i love bad
batches that's a [ __ ] problem
and in this video so but in this video
yeah keep
stick with me we're gonna be breaking
down episode six of the bad batch
there's a lot of easter eggs hidden
details and things going on in this
entry and throughout the video we'll be
going over them whilst also giving our
theories on what could be happening next
full spoilers ahead so if you don't want
anything ruined then the video is going
to be a little short like yoda
please drop a thumbs up if you enjoy the
breakdown and don't forget to subscribe
for videos with puns in
alderaan places without the way thank
you for clicking this
now let's get into bad batch episode 6.
okay so up top
quick correction on the last video in
that we said we're halfway through the
season
but as many of you pointed out the
series is actually going to have 16
episodes
so you've got 10 more weeks of me
talking utter nonsense
i'm making constant mistakes maybe i'll
get put in charge of star wars eh are
you having a
tata now episode five saw the batch
going to odd mantel
which was first name dropped in the
empire strikes back
here they were given a job by sid to
rescue a rancor named muchi
and this led to them going head-to-head
with some zygerrian slavers
throughout the episode it became clear
that something is up with wrecker's head
namely his chip we said that he's likely
now a chip off the old block
and dealing with several of the issues
that we've seen in the clones thus far
we'll be discussing this later on in the
video but the amount of head rubbing
that's been going on in this season
just has been absolutely crazy omega
also managed to get a brand new weapon
and shout outs to ryan arya at screen
crush for pointing out that this is an
energy bow
which is a primary weapon of the night
sisters of dathomir
after learning of fenix shan the batch
remained on odd mantel
and the episode titled decommissioned
refers to several things
in the star wars canon firstly the main
objective in the episode is to retrieve
a droid before it's
decommissioned however the meaning goes
far beyond that
when the clones were replaced it was
simply stated that they were
decommissioned
and this phrasing has a lot of subtext
to it
typically when you decommission
something you're referring to a product
and not a person
and it very much shows how the empire
view the clones as items
rather than actual people they are seen
in the same vein as the droids
and if the empire is willing to get rid
of them you can bet that they'll do the
same thing to others that they don't
really view as life forms
i think the bats see a lot of
similarities between themselves and the
droids
and this further pushes them away from
the imperials
now i love this panning shot at the
start of the episode that shows someone
feeling like i will tomorrow morning
it's friday now we catch omega
practicing with a bow
and this could be a little nod to a new
hope namely when luke was figuring out
how to use a lightsaber
she keeps failing but after some kind
words from an elder
she gains a lot more confidence again
just
say it with mia it's like poetry they
rhyme
the aliens from last week also return
and we get a much better look at them
we can now see that they're a nitherian
and also a weak way
both of these have appeared in numerous
star wars properties with the first
appearing in a new hope
the latter species were used as jabba's
gods as well as the bartender in episode
1 of season 2 of the mandalorian
typically both species are a bit douchey
so i love the fact that they keep
shouting for her to miss
sid tells them of a tactical droid and
we discover that it's being sent to
corellia to be decommissioned
now firstly corellia is the home planet
of han solo
and if you've seen han solo movie then
you will no doubt recognize the location
as the place we start off at now shout
out simon a birman on twitter for
pointing out that corellia is one of the
planets where the empire makes their
ships
and other vehicles like star destroyers
and 8080s
you also told me that the voice actor
for omega is actually 37 years old
and shout outs michelle ang for doing a
stellar job on portraying a little kid
the tactical droids have also appeared
throughout the clone wars
and they also popped up in solo too
these were typically used to plan our
battle strategies
and because of this they possess a
wealth of knowledge
sid very much becomes their agent and it
is possible she'll be getting them to go
on mercenary jobs in the future
she did mention last week that she had
connections to the guild
i can't see her sort of being this
series grief koga
the match attached to his ship to sneak
past the sensors
and echo says this old trick and of
course did something similar in the
empire strikes back
and i'm not even gonna bother saying it
also yeah before you start
i know this takes place before that
movie now we see several police droids
and also learn that wrecker doesn't like
heights typically
clones were programmed to have as little
fear as possible
and thus this shows how he differs from
the typical grunt
in this smelting factory we can also see
several battle droids being destroyed
this is sort of the opposite of the
factory that anakin and padme went
through an attack of the clones
where they were of course created the
group go through the facility
and discover that as luck would have it
there's one tactical droid left
omega discovers its head but it's
pinched by trace
hui learners at the factory with his
sister rapha
you might recognize these two as
ahsoka's friends in the clone wars
and we learned that when they were
younger they lived on level 1313 on core
ascent
this was the underworld of the planet
and sadly whenever i hear that
i think of the cancelled star wars game
hashtag never forget
it was gonna be a classic and i swear
we'll always miss your buddy
now things all go to hell and after an
arrow is accidentally fired in the
factory
the entire place starts to go into
meltdown it's quickly locked down
and police droids end up going into the
area one says ichita
which is a hutty's curse in star wars
this was first said by e3po in the
empire strikes back
after c-3pl tried to chat her up sort of
a three-way struggle with the sisters
bad match in the droids
all trying to get what they're after and
raka has to face his fears to help lift
the lock down
he further batters his head once more
and we discover that his chip has indeed
activated
he starts to say good soldier which is
what several of the clones uttered after
the brainwashing came into full effect
crosshair's words also echo in his head
about how good soldiers always follow
orders following orders is something
that has been uttered by several of the
clone troopers
and during order 66 it was pretty much
mentioned by most of them
when they were asked why they did what
they did i think it's really going to be
interesting to see how this develops
but at least we got a fan theory right
and didn't completely
mephisto the entire series i think that
we will probably come across a jedi at
some point in this season
potentially ahsoka and that he will
attempt to kill her
this will show that the chip has indeed
activated and it will also force the
group to find a way to stop it
upon doing this they'll realize how to
deactivate it in crosshair
and i think the second half of the
season will be about saving him
now we will be talking about ahsoka
later on but there are some big clues
that she's coming down the line
from here hunter cleverly takes down the
support posts in the factory to destroy
the droids
and they manage to save omega from
getting the anakin treatment
now though i absolutely love this season
up until this point
i think that the series has been a
little light on action
i know it's had its moments but i've
never really felt there's been a scene
where the batch are truly in danger
whereas here finally they're facing some
real odds
rapha and trace realize that if they
want to make it out they'll have to work
together
and the batch also copied the data on
the tactical droid
in order for them to get the best of
both worlds they also pull several
droids from the assembly line to help
out
and they say how they never thought
they'd end up on the same side
this is definitely hinting towards the
moral shades of grey
that the group are of course now working
in omega finally masters the bow
and they manage to make it out by the
skin of their teeth
on rapher and trace's ship we see a
yellowy green astromech droid
and we learn at the end that this is r7
cast your mind back to the clone wars
and you'll remember that ahsoka's droid
was r7 a7
so i think its inclusion here confirms
that their mystery contact is indeed her
as i said earlier i think the whole chip
thing in wrecker's head will lead to him
trying to assassinate a jedi upon seeing
them
and the setup of ahsoka here definitely
brings that all together
they say their contact is trying to
fight the empire and though this could
be a number of people
the fact that they possess her droid
makes the most sense to me
however let me know below if you think
differently as it may even be someone
like bail organa
or even saw guerrera hunter gives the
tactical droid info that tech copy to
the sisters
as he realizes they'll use it for better
reasons than the batch ever will
hunter says things were clearer when
they were just soldiers
to which we get a note about how we all
choose sights in the end
the bad batch have clearly chosen theirs
and we end the episode with the sisters
reaching out to their contact they say
there's a rogue set of clones
and ahsoka has of course dealt with the
likes of captain rex
all in all probably my favorite episode
so far and lots to speculate about
so let me know your thoughts below now
as for my thoughts on the season so far
i feel a bit like a jedi whilst watching
it
this week-to-week release schedule
requires great patience
and means that one must sit and wait for
this big plot to unfold fully
i feel like there's a lot to come back
for week to week though but i'm still
undecided as to whether this would work
better as a big binge
or in the way that it's being released
16 weeks is a long time
but i must say that i'm really enjoying
the story that they're telling in the
show
i think whenever star wars introduces
new characters at the moment
it's often a coin toss over whether
they're going to be loved or hated
but for the most part i would say all
the new editions like omega are working
really well
search your feelings you know it to be
true and it's nice that in a show
centered around the bad batch
they've managed to introduce a brand new
element that was completely unconnected
from them
and weaved them into the show really
really well every week feels like a big
new adventure in the star wars expanded
lore that leaves you wanting more and at
the end of each episode i'm curious to
see who could pop up next time
or where they could end up we're barely
scratching the surface here
and the fact we've still got 10 episodes
left bean says a lot of plot avenues
that they can explore
i'm kind of hoping the story kicks up a
gear and just goes all out crazy
but there's still plenty of time for
them to develop the characters before
they fully throw them in at the deep end
with the empire
anyway that's my thoughts on the show so
far and we'll of course be back
next friday with a brand new breakdown
on the next episode
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the bad batch
so make sure you comment below and let
me know as a thank you for interacting
with the video you'll be entered into a
prize during the 30th of june
in which we're giving away three copies
of the mcu phase 3 box set
all you have to do to be with the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the episode the winners of
last month's competition are on screen
right now
so if that's you then message me on
twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
last week
or you know just whatever's linked on
screen right now
by the way thank you for sitting through
the video i've been poor i'll see you
next time
take care peace
[Music]